marta kaufman who's the creator of
the uh
what i think
next to seinfeld may be the at least is
the second most overrated sitcom of all
time friends
she's been on an apology tour recently
and i'm not exactly sure why she's been
doing this now in particular i don't
know i guess she has something she's
promoting she's got another show coming
out i don't know that exactly but i
could only assume that she's got
something else she's working on and so
she wants to set things right with the
woke brigade so she's been going around
trying to write all of the unwoke wrongs
that her series committed somehow back
in the 90s now i was never as noted
never a big fan of friends i've seen a
few of the episodes
it always struck me even in the 90s as
pretty politically correct
okay it never would have occurred to me
that there's anything
offensive to the left in friends but
apparently there is there's quite a lot
so for the last few weeks she's been
going around apologizing for all of the
various groups that were hurt by friends
somehow
in an effort to become an ally now so
we'll start with this she appeared on
talk tv this was at the end of june a
couple weeks ago to talk about the
racism on her show i had no idea there
was racism but there was
as she confesses here but she's gonna
set things right
and uh listen to this
it took me
a long time to begin to understand
how i
internalized
systemic racism
and i've been working really really hard
to
become an ally anti-racist
and this seemed to me to be a way that i
could
participate
in the conversation
from
a white woman's perspective
i hope
it becomes
the leading
aaas department in the country i hope
that
this department gets everything it needs
financially
and can
continue
to engage students
and
i hope it widens
okay so she
one thing she's been doing for the last
uh i don't know exactly everything she's
been up to since friends went off the
air but it's very clear that she's been
studying
wokeness and she's been studying it
closely because
she knows she she speaks the language
now she had it all down you know
do the work participate in the
conversation all this kind of stuff it's
still not clear to me so what exactly
was racist about friends it's not it's
not clear i guess it's because there was
a there weren't enough black actors on
on the show and so he raced
uh
apparently this at least i've learned i
can assume this is what she's talking
about because this is what i've seen
from other left people on social media
that friends erased black people by not
having enough of them on
the sitcom so i don't know if you are a
black person you might not even realize
that you were erased by a sitcom in the
90s but you were
and you sh and if you don't feel harmed
and damaged by that you should
this even according to the co-creator of
the show she even says that so now she's
pledging it's uh four million dollars to
support african and african-american
studies
uh so she's trying to heal the racial
wounds created by friends because of
that but it's not just racial wounds um
look anytime
there's an occasion where someone is a
victim
we know that uh that the trans club
they're gonna they're gonna find their
way in to that conversation okay no one
is uh
nobody in this country is allowed to be
a victim by themselves without including
trans people trans people are also
victims if you think you're a victim
there's always going to be um uh the
trans club coming right behind to say no
me too oh yeah i'm also a victim of this
so she was she appeared on bbc last
night in an interview
to confess to very various pronoun
related atrocities let's listen to that
criticism
is
it's difficult i mean
friends has been criticized
in a number of ways
the biggest one being that we did not
have enough representation of black
people and over the course of the last
few years
i have gotten to the point where i can
say
unfortunately yes i'm guilty of that i
am guilty of that
and i'll never make that mistake again i
was
clearly part of
systemic racism in our business i was
unaware of that which makes me feel
stupid
so yeah that was a very valid extremely
difficult
criticism which still
i get emotional about
if i knew then what i know now there are
certain things i would have changed but
i didn't know them and i have since
learned here's one
we kept referring to her as chandler's
father
even though chandler's
father was trans
pronouns were not yet something
that i understood
so we didn't refer to that character as
she
oh pronoun
she goes she's getting emotional she's
getting choked up
um she's still
20 years later she's still crying about
the fact she's distraught because there
were enough black actors and friends and
also because she she misgendered
uh who is it chandler's
trans dad is that what it was
so that's why you would think that we
that the left would celebrate
friends for being ahead of its time i
didn't even realize this until just now
but so so one of the characters on
friends had a cross-dressing or trans or
whatever uh parent so you'd think that
the left would
would be celebrating and it says ahead
of its time
in the 90s to have that kind of
character
but but no because even though it was
ahead of its time it still had not yet
caught because it existed in the past it
wasn't aligned with what people are
saying and doing
in the year 2022
um which which is just a an unforgivable
sin
and so atonement must be made and that's
what she's doing now
it's no surprise to see this you know
especially from people in hollywood in
order to find success in hollywood to
begin with you have to empty yourself
most of the time you have to empty
yourself of um
you know your
and any real personality any real
convictions
and you just become this empty shell of
a human being
um and that's why she has no problem i
mean this anyone else i think if you if
you had
like a spine and a soul you would at
least be embarrassed
to be doing this apology tour for a
sitcom that you made 30 years ago
but she has none of that there's no
dignity so there's nothing to worry
about for her
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast
you